la 205 en panne la grève se poursuit à
peugeot mulhouse les syndicats
n'acceptent pas les propositions de la
direction
mazowiecki fessée compte 12 membres de
solidarité dans son gouvernement dont
diasec couronne mais aussi cinq
ministres communistes
la fin d'une époque pour le nucléaire
français
la centrale de chinon va fermer ses
portes elle ne ferait plus que la
priorité les festayres
meilleur temps pour les ferrari vous ai
fait de monza devant senna et prost mais
le français est la coqueluche des tifosi
depuis qu'il a signé chez ferrari
bonsoir et avant de développer tous ses
titres cet accident d'avion on vient de
l'apprendre un avion norvégien s'est
écrasé en mer du nord
aujourd'hui avec 55 personnes à bord il
assuré la liaison entre oslo en norvège
et hambourg en allemagne il y avait donc
55 personnes à bord des navires se sont
déjà portés sur les lieux du drame
et à l'instant je l'apprends par cette
dépêche de l'afp et il n'y aurait aucun
survivant à bord de l'appareil norvégien
c'est ce qu'a affirmé tout à l'heure un
officier danois bien sûr si nous avons
d'autres informations sur cet accident
d'avion nous y reviendrons dans le
courant de ce journal mais voyons
maintenant l'actualité de le reste de
l'actualité de ce vendredi
la semaine qui s'achève a été celle de
la rentrée scolaire
chacun commence à connaître ces profs on
s'habitue aux horaires on s'organise
pour l'année et la rentrée s'est passée
correctement avec toutefois deux points
non d'abord les classes trop nombreuses
dans les lycées jusqu'à 39 40 élèves
nous vous en avons déjà parlé et puis il
y à l'afflux dans les maternelles les
parents travaillent de plus en plus bien
sûr et c'est l'engorgement
il y a déjà deux millions cinq cent
mille enfants dans les maternelles mais
il n'y a pas assez de place d'où le
mécontentement de certains parents qui
ne peuvent pas inscrire leurs enfants
exemple monique atlan et bernard connor
se sont rendus dans le 19e
arrondissement de paris
on la sait pas c'est inadmissible et
désolé là il faut faire quelque chose
ils sont 27 à la maternelle de la rue
des voix dans le 19ème à n'avoir pu
aller en classe ce matin à l'école de
l'avenue parmentier ils sont 60 dans une
autre école du 10e arrondissement 40 des
exemples parmi d'autres de la situation
confuse de cette rentrée scolaire en
maternelle ici à la rue des bois les
parents affolés ont décidé d'agir
les occupent les lieux pour protester
contre la suppression d'une classe qui
empêche ainsi l'accueil d'enfants en âge
d'être déjà scolarisés concrètement je
vais occuper la classe qui doit être
pourvu donc je vais prendre mes
responsabilités deux parents à savoir
que je vais prendre un garde mon enfant
et les enfants qui sont concernés qui
ont le même cas que l'autre est bon
jusqu'à ce que le
le rectorat fournissent un poste massive
d'un côté on les inscrit
est on obligé de donner ma démission à
les koalas à la crèche et d'un autre
côté on les accepte pas ici alors on est
bien embêté quoi et nous tenons à faire
savoir une phrase ou que nous occupons
le rectorat lundi après midi
prise entre le marteau et l'enclume la
directrice réclame une solution
d'urgence von guericke six mois chez sur
responsable de la bonne marche et je
demande que cette classe est ouverte
je suis là pour accueillir les enfants
qui s'inscrit d'amendé il faut savoir
que nous appliquerons bien entendu les
objectifs du ministère en ce qui
concerne la scolarisation des enfants en
maternelle c'est à dire que nous
essaierons de scolariser le plus
d'enfants de 3 ans et dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaires ceux de plus de
deux ans
mais pour l'heure l'éducation nationale
ne semble pas s'être réellement donner
les moyens d'aboutir à l'application
concrète de ces directives c'est vrai
l'enseignement en france à quelques
problèmes on le sait mais consolation
peut-être nous ne sommes pas les seuls
comme le prouve ce coup d'oeil chez nos
amis anglais
là-bas outre-manche il y a une véritable
fuite des professeurs du public vers le
privé en quête de philippe harrouard le
jour de la rentrée en angleterre cette
enseignante a été très remarquée non
pour ses capacités mais pour sa
nationalité
liona hoffmann est hollandaise l
enseigne l'anglais aux petits
britanniques
elle n'est pas la seule dans ce cas la
pénurie d'enseignants dans le secteur
public a conduit les autorités locales à
recruter des maîtres étrangers suédois
danois australiens 6 en province la
situation est à peu près normale à
londres et dans sa région il a fallu
renvoyer des élèves faute de m cela est
arrivé dans une douzaine d'écoles des
quartiers les plus hauts à londres il
manque toujours 200 enseignants au
niveau national plus de 3000 postes sont
vacants sur 400 me
il y à une crise de confiance des
enseignants d'après un récent sondage un
sur trois petit et la profession tout
est pas le moral le salaire la
qualification et surtout l'estiment il
ya quelques années il y avait des gens
qui pensaient qu être prof c'était une
grande chose et maintenant non quand
j'étais à la faculté
c'était vraiment l impression que les
gens qui voulaient être prof
netiq les gens qui ne savaient pas fait
quoi faire de réforme en réforme le
gouvernement tente de redorer le blason
de l'école publique toujours considéré
comme un parent pauvre d'un système
éducatif dominé par la compétition entre
les écoles privées les grévistes de
peugeot mulhouse sont continuer leur
mouvement la grève reprendra lundi une
très forte majorité l'a voté ce matin
après les propositions de la direction
c'était une augmentation de 1 et demi
pour cent et les grévistes la jugent
tout à fait insuffisantes enquête à
mulhouse
sophie jouve yanncik elle
cet après midi à l'usiné peugeot de
mulhouse les commentaires allaient bon
train
à l'issue de la réunion de coordination
une même détermination chez des
grévistes on continue à nous ont déjà
des contres
alors on espère un minimum de safran sur
glace pas au minimum et plus ce qui
était possible et donc vous êtes prête à
poursuivre le mouvement au temps qu'il
faudra on peut pas lâcher maintenant
maintenant ya pratiquement tout le monde
avec nous il faut se relâcher maintenant
à quoi ça sert les travailleurs en ont
marre de voir que peugeot en poche des
bénéfices monde ce sont les actionnaires
qui en profitent et pas les travailleurs
ce matin le premier face à face
direction syndicat n'a donc pas permis
de sortir de l'impasse 1,5 pour cent
d'augmentation applicable à l'ensemble
du groupe
la direction affirme pour le moment ne
pas pouvoir faire plus les entreprises
savent bien que les résultats de du
travail doit être partagé entre les
investissements aient les salaires si on
ne veut pas relancer l'inflation
eh bien nous devons avoir une politique
salariale qui est celle que nous avons
les grévistes ont quitté les locaux
décidés à reprendre dès lundi le
mouvement le temps qu'il faudra distille
pour toucher leur part du redressement
du groupe
pour la direction la marge de manoeuvre
est étroite voire la production de la
205 paralyse à mulhouse ou lâcher un peu
de lest sur les salaires mais là elle
s'expose à ce que les autres unités
peugeot réclament la même chose voilà un
conflit à mulhouse donc mais comme c'est
le premier conflit important gérard
leclerc tout le monde le surveille ce
conflit tout l'ensemble de groupe
peugeot bien sûr mais aussi le patronat
mais aussi le gouvernement absolument et
d'abord sous la surveillance de peugeot
depuis le naufrage de talbot il ya six
ans le groupe n'a pas connu de conflit
majeur malgré une austérité salariale
très rude pour le pdg jacques calvet
c'était le prix à payer hier pour
retrouver les bénéfices et rembourser
les dettes
aujourd'hui pour reconstituer un trésor
de guerre équivalents à ceux de foals
hagen ou monde et salariés de mulhouse
ont fini par craquer et y aura-t-il
contagion dans les autres usines
c'est toute la question deuxième
observateurs donc le patronat sans faire
de bruit les entreprises ont plutôt bien
géré la détente salariale qui exigeait
le retour de la croissance
quelques augmentations primeur
supplémentaires intéressement
soigneusement distillé ont mis de
l'huile dans les rouages sans emballer
la machine mais l'équilibré reste
fragile
et puis bien sûr il ya le gouvernement
qui surveille ça très attentive et wii
et qui est à l'affût parce que les
entreprises ne peuvent pas
produire plus faute d'avoir suffisamment
investi dans le passé une relance de la
consommation par les salaires
entraînerait immanquablement selon le
gouvernement des importations donc une
nouvelle dégradation du commerce
extérieur
mais le discours n'est pas facile à
faire passer quand les profits et la
bourse s'en veulent tous les jours pour
ses fonctionnaires le gouvernement
espère s'en sortir en déminant les
conflits éventuels un par un et en
négociant les fameux pacte de croissance
c'est à dire des primes liées aux
résultats économiques et intégrables
plus tard dans les salaires une
stratégie fragile qui ne résisterait pas
longtemps à de fortes secousses sociales
merci gérard dans l'actualité sociale
encore le problème des ptt vous savez
que l'on parle de les séparer en deux
d'un côté la poste de l'autre côté les
télécommunications et bien cet
après-midi le ministre discutait avec
les syndicats de cela mais aussi
beaucoup d'autres choses
déjà la cgt a refusé de discuter de ce
problème sur place au ministère des ptt
maryse malo autour du tapis vert paul
quilès et ce matin qu'il joue la réforme
des ptt
comme la cgt a refusé de négocier sur
les bases du rapport prévost le ministre
doit convaincre les trois autres
syndicats de l'urgence de la réforme
mais pour assurer leur base inquiète les
trois syndicats sont venus avec une
liste de conditions préalables à la
négociation véritable mais aucun n'a
claqué la porte
pas même force ouvrière la plus
réfractaire aux rapports prévost un bon
point pour paul quilès qui s'est
empressé d'accepter à la demande de la
cfdt une négociation sur les
qualifications et l'évolution de
carrière aux ptt il y a une volonté que
je sentis partagée chez mes
interlocuteurs volonté
d'aboutir vers des objectifs qui sont
les mêmes et chaque organisation
syndicale personnes que j'ai rencontrées
malgré les points de vue qui peuvent
être différents affirmer très clairement
que nous avions les mêmes objectifs
faisant le ministre semble prêt à
accepter beaucoup de conditions pourvu
qu'elle ne ferme pas la porte à une
réforme qu'ils jugent nécessaires le
rapport prévu n'est qu'une base de
discussion ce qui est certain ce soir
c'est qu'il n'est toujours pas enterré
la faire autant lara suite le ministre
de la justice vient à l'instant de
décider d'engager les poursuites
judiciaires contre le cinéaste pour
injures raciales diffamation raciale et
provocation à la haine raciale
cette décision fait suite bien sûr aux
déclarations de claude autant-lara
publié par le magazine globe
ce vendredi on avait appris que le
cinéaste avait démissionné de la vice
présidence de l'académie des beaux-arts
à la demande de marcel landowski qui est
le secrétaire perpétuel de cette
académie choqué par les propos
antisémites
d'autant lara au mensuel globe jean
marie le pen était tout à l'heure à
dijon eh bien il a mis en cause le
magazine globe mais tout de même il a
désavoué claude autant lara
écoutez monsieur le pen il s'agit pas
d'une interview il s'agit d'une
conversation téléphonique extorquer un
jeu monsieur et cela ne constitue pas
l'élément d'actualité que l'on dit il y
à une escroquerie dans le fait de
publier des conversations qui n'ont pas
été faites pour cela ses propos monsieur
le pen est ce que vous auriez pu les
tenir
non je ne les tiens pas si je les avais
tenu cela se saurait alors je ne les ai
pas tenu et considère que la mise en
cause de madame veil -le et est tout à
fait
critiquable d'ailleurs madame veil à
l'exception de tous les autres
commentateurs a eu une position en effet
digne elle s'est abstenue de commenter
mon activité politique ce week-end ça
bouillonne dans les partis le ps réunit
800 responsables à evry dans l'essonne
à droite on se rassemble en université
d'été le p r par exemple partie
république à perpignan et le rpr tout
près à saint cyprien au bord du golfe à
retenir de cette journée au rpr alain
carignon qui a décidé de créer son
propre courant
et puis les jeunes du mouvement qui ont
de nouveau exprimé quelques états d'âme
avec en perspective pour tous la
reconquête du pouvoir
olivier lerner au passé au présent et au
futur il conjugue depuis ce matin quatre
verbes réforme et modernisé rénové
unifiée
chacun à son niveau reprend goût à la
vie politique
matignon est déjà d'actualité
il ya beaucoup d'hommes au rpr qui ont
les dimensions et la compétence pour
être enlevée nice alors qui par exemple
beaucoup je vous laisse le soin de les
chercher là qu'ils ont et elle a
d'autres qui ne seront déterminés à
votre avis pour lui une dernière
question il s'agit alors cherchons
ailleurs seguin noir par zac pasqua et
pourquoi pas juppé
si jacques chirac a déjà donné je ne
suis pas l'exégèse d'alain juppé
ce que je sais c'est que les jeunes qui
sont ici sont ici pour jacques chirac
cette nouvelle affiche donne le la alain
carignon rénovateurs s'est fait un
plaisir d'interpréter ce nouveau concept
il annonce la création de son propre
court s'il ne faut pas pratiqué
l'euthanasie
il ne faut pas non plus pratiquer
l'avortement
il faut que les naissances tous puissent
se développer dans un grand mouvement
applaudissements nourris dans la salle
mais alain juppé reste insensible il a
tout rose oud et à proposer moment est
venu de grèce qu'on pourrait appeler par
exemple le conseil supérieur de
l'opposition il pourrait se réunir tous
les mois est l'une des premières tâches
qu'ils devraient s'assigner c'est de
voir comment mettre en musique ce qui a
été proposé par charles pasqua et par
d'autres ensuite à savoir la procédure
des primaires à la française pour les
prochaines élections présidentielles
pour cause de mauvais temps la plage de
saint cyprien est abandonné un temps
propice pour une rentrée politique
jacques chirac arrive demain il tentera
d'effacer lé mauvais souvenir dans
l'actualité internationale la chine
d'abord la basse et la normalisation un
peu plus dur chaque jour avec plusieurs
maîtres mots répression emprisonnement
exécution
l'armée tente de se justifier auprès de
la population témoin ce musée que les
militaires présentes au public et au
plein centre de pékin
les envoyés spéciaux de notre magazine
résistance dominique torrès notamment
ont visité ce curieux musée et ils se
sont rendus compte que l'effet sur la
population n'était pas celui attendu par
les militaires reportage
les militaires mais aussi des étudiants
les anciens combattants des événements
de juin sont au rendez vous l'inventaire
complet chars calcinés véhicules brûlés
toute la panoplie de la propagande
contre révolutionnaire du calicot autres
actes on précise bien 1280 véhicules
brûlés l'exposition militaire ne
désemplit pas les mâts sont vivement
conviés à s'imprégner de la vérité la
vérité officielle
à l'intérieur on ne lésine pas sur les
moyens des photos souvenirs
l'historique des événements
les armes du crime mais ce qui retient
la faveur du public
les tracts les traque des étudiants qui
se lisent ici avec une extrême attention
le clou de l'exposition un film fleuve
qui retrace à sa manière le printemps de
pékin
on peut voir les étudiants violents et
des voiliers en pleine action et les
bons militaires tous ceux jeunes des
patriotes
jean-guy non ceux là n'ont pas hésité à
payer de leur vie pour éviter de tirer
sur le peuple
wills assure-t-on il ya eu des morts en
juin
tous des militaires
est ce que tu viens de voir les tracts
oui je voulais connaître la pensée
révolutionnaire du peuple
c'est un peu bizarre faire le but de
l'exposition est précisément d'informer
les gens sur les crimes commis par les
bandits contre révolutionnaire je ne
crois pas qu'ils soient des
contre-révolutionnaires
c'est le gouvernement qui les appelle
ainsi si j'en à lui entre le système
féodal
nous sommes en effet dans un système
féodal il faut un courage un courage
presque insensé pour s'exprimer ainsi
aujourd'hui à pékin jeudi prochain au
cours de la soirée vous pourrez voir le
magazine résistance justement contrats
créés à la chine
la pologne à l'heure des dosages
politique on connaît maintenant la
composition probable du futur
gouvernement polonais qui devrait être
ratifiée la semaine prochaine par le
parlement polonais cinq sièges donc pour
le parti communiste et 12 postes de
ministres pour solidarité le premier
ministre monsieur masure rizki à doser
avec beaucoup de doigté
jacques nerling dans quatre jours le
nouveau gouvernement polonais sera
investi par le parlement si aucun
changement n'intervient d'ici là ce
gouvernement sera majorité composée de
membres de solidarité
il aurait 12 portefeuilles dont les
affaires étrangères les finances le
travail la communication et donc la
télévision l'éducation l'industrie et la
culture
parmi les noms de ces nouveaux ministres
on remarque évidemment celui d'oeil à
ses couronnes ici en bras de chemise qui
sera ministre du travail un poste très
exposé et c'est lui qui devra faire
accepter l'austérité aux salariés le
temps de remettre l'économie sur pieds
il ya ces couronnes qui a passé neuf
années en prison
ces jeux sera aux côtés de celui qu'il a
mis plusieurs fois derrière les barreaux
le général qui chaque qui reste ministre
l'intérieur
les communistes conserve également la
défense les transports et le commerce
extérieur les petit parti paysan
démocrates se partagent les six
portefeuilles restant sur ce
gouvernement trois observations la
première est un rappel c'est que
solidarité ne souhaitait pas former un
gouvernement
dès maintenant le syndicat a franchi le
pas ce qu'il pense que gorbatchev était
affaiblie et qui convient d'aller vite
avant que des changements éventuels et
lieu en urss
la seconde observation est que dans
cette affaire solidarité prend tous les
risques
c'est lui qui va détenir tous les
ministères à caractère économique
il va lui falloir dans les prochains
mois reconstruire l'économie dans le
plus complet désordre
c'est une tâche énorme et puis troisième
observation n'oublions pas que 90% des
responsables de l'administration de la
police de la diplomatie et même du
secteur privé de l'économie sont des
membres du parti communiste par leur
inertie ou leur position ils peuvent
faire toutes échoué l'expérience en tout
cas serait unique s'interrompt un court
instant le cours de ce journal pour
revenir à la faire autant lara je vous
le disais tout à l'heure le garde des
sceaux le ministre de la justice pierre
arpaillange a décidé d'engager des
poursuites judiciaires contre le
cinéaste après ses propos antisémites
qu'il a tenus au magazine globe avec
nous en direct tout de suite au
téléphone le ministre de la justice
alors monsieur arpaillange qu'est ce qui
vous a amené à engager des poursuites
que à paris cet après midi j'ai étudié
c'est et et cabinet s'était point de vue
juridique ce que l'on pouvait en penser
et la suite j'ai demandé au public de
requérir l'ouverture des informations
déchets des jurassiens de sommation
raciale de provocation à la haine
raciale et de complicité pour autant
l'arrêt toujours nous les attendus
monsieur le ministre parce que vous
attendiez la parution imminente du
mensuel globe en matière de presse que
d'y avoir une fois ci on pénalise le
losc
la publication journal rapporte des
propos qu'on tient des propos incriminés
régulière je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable monsieur le ministre mais est ce
qu'on ne peut pas penser que ces propos
tenus par le cinéaste claude autant lara
est ce
les propos d'un homme âgé qui se
contrôle plus très bien et côté je crois
que il ya différents aspects à
considérer
je crois que c'est un des arguments
qu'avait invoqué simone veil pour
demander que les bretons qui l'a
concerné personnellement et directement
le font pas l'objet de poursuites mais
un tour de moulin est en fête
interview tes bagages l'erika mont
chauve être soumise aux tripes merci
monsieur le ministre merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
aussi rapidement je reviens maintenant
au cours du journal nous parlions de
l'actualité internationale voici
maintenant le problème de l'afrique du
sud avec une polémique après les
affrontements qui ont eu lieu au cap
hier douze morts 23 morts personne n'est
d'accord pour l'instant qui a provoqué
la police ou les manifestants chacun
défend sa thèse vers l'afrique du sud
les lendemains d'élections sont bien
amer martine laroche-joubert la douleur
des mères devant les caméras
la preuve d'après l'archevêque anglican
desmond toutou qui les réunit cet après
midi autour de lui que les policiers ont
tué 29 personnes
les maires que moigne les blessés montre
leur plaît les allégations mensongères
selon les forces de l'ordre sud
africaine les morts une dizaine seraient
les victimes d'affrontements entre des
factions rivales de version qui
s'affrontent et un homme interpellé par
desmond toutou frederik de klerk qu'il
adjure d'ordonner une enquête et de
témoigner sa sympathie pour les familles
des victimes à l'extérieur de la
cathédrale
les avocats anti apartheid chanteuse
désigne la police se fait très discrète
pas d'incident semble-t-il aujourd'hui
dans les townships quelques pneus qui
brûlent pas davantage dans les townships
on attend maintenant le jour des
funérailles des funérailles qui auront
lieu plus tard que prévu les corps des
victimes seront en effet autopsiés pour
déterminer la cause de leur mort ici
comment cela dit une semaine de deuil
l'allemagne créer un géant de
l'industrie un géant de l'industrie
allemande bien sûr ce sera la plus
grosse entreprise allemands mais aussi
un géant de l'industrie mondiale
il s'agit de la fusion entre daimler
benz la fameuse firme de mercedes et
messerschmidt autre fameux société
spécialisée elle vous le savez dans
l'aviation
voyons maintenant d'autres informations
internationales à commencer par ce
nouvel attentat de l'ira les terroristes
irlandais en allemagne l'ira a tué une
femme par erreur jérôme baugnies
c'est une erreur qui a coûté la vie à
l'épousé d'un soldat britannique tué
d'une rafale de kalachnikov d'hier soir
à dortmund en allemagne fédérale l'ira
l'armée républicaine irlandaise qui a
revendiqué aujourd'hui l'attentât a
reconnu que la jeune femme de
nationalité allemande qui circulait dans
la voiture de son mari avait été prise
pour un membre des forces royales
britanniques réaction énergique de
margaret thatcher condamnant les actions
lâche le terroriste à l'encontre de
personnes innocentes et sans défense
c'est en deux semaines le troisième
attentat de l'ira sur le sol allemand
visant en principe des militaires
britanniques
le rythme cardiaque de mère teresa est
irrégulier mais elle va mieux
hospitalisé mardi matin dans une
clinique de calcutta à la suite d'un
malaise cardiaque
la sainte des trottoirs qui consacre sa
vie aux plus déshérités dans les
bidonvilles de l'inde et du monde a
retrouvé aujourd'hui son sourire
pourtant le prix nobel de la paix âgé de
79 ans devra se reposer son corps
quelques jours arrimage mouvementée du
vaisseau soviétique soyouz avec la
station orbitale mir frisson pour les
cosmonautes victorin co et serebrov
alors qu'ils arrivent à 4 mètres de
l'objectif pour un arrimage qui devrait
être entièrement automatique la station
se met à vibrer le commandant de bord
doit reprendre les commandes manuelles
la jonction est finalement réussi avec
quelques minutes de retard
les cosmonautes sont maintenant au
travail dans cette station mir inhabité
depuis cinq mois
pour des raisons techniques déjà la fin
d'une époque pour le nucléaire français
la direction d'edf vient en effet
d'annoncer l'arrêt définitif du réacteur
3 de la centrale de chinon conçu avec
une technologie française il ya bientôt
20 ans cette centrale aurait dû subir
des rénovations très coûteuse pour
offrir toutes les garanties de sécurité
nécessaires
explications de notre spécialiste
patrick esther sinon à 3 est l'une des
centrales nucléaires construites à la
fin des années 60
suivant une technologie développée à la
demande du général de gaulle par les
ingénieurs français du commissariat à
l'énergie atomique
ce type de réacteur fonctionne en
utilisant de l'uranium naturel et du
graphite gaz
mais cette technologie vieille malle
l'entretien du réacteur de chinon à
trois a déjà nécessité par deux fois des
travaux très coûteux
le service central de sûreté des
installations nucléaires de plus
est-il que pour offrir une réelle
garantie de sécurité l'ensemble du
circuit primaire de la centrale c'est à
dire sa partie la plus dangereuse parce
que radioactives
ce circuit primaire donc devait faire
l'objet d'une expertise très poussée une
demande qui s'explique par le fait que
les centres à la graphie de gaz ne
possède pas d'enceintes capable de
confiner une éventuelle explosion
devant le coût très élevé les futurs
travaux à envisager la direction d'edf a
préféré décidé d'abandonner purement et
simplement le réacteur dès le printemps
prochain
c'est à dire lorsque le combustible
nucléaire dont il est chargé sera brûlée
il ne restera plus alors que trois
réacteurs graphite gaz en service en
france 2 à saint laurent des eaux et un
obus j'ai un peu de sport maintenant
c'est toujours bon pour la santé
en tennis première qualifiée pour la
finale de l'us open c'est martina
navratilova elle a battu sa compatriote
l'américaine deena garrison en deux sets
et puis les premiers essais du grand
prix de formule 1 de monza ce sont les
ferrari ce qu'ils ont réalisé les deux
meilleurs temps vers guerre et mansell
aux deux premières places
senna et prost sont juste derrière à
monza cette année prost sera la vedette
car il vient de signer vous le savez
chez ferrari
autre français très en vue en formule 1
jean alesi
pour ses premières courses il a déjà
fait des miracles lionel chamoulaud
claude sicard
une dame à la cagoule a deux casquettes
l'une en formule 1 avec tyrrell l'autre
on formule 3000 ans rêve pas il débuts
en formule 3000 il est leader du
championnat du monde
une double activité éprouvante pour le
jeune français
le rythme était terrible tous les
dimanches des courses comme ça c'est ça
devient fatiguant pas pénible
au contraire c est super de couvrir tous
les dimanches mais physiquement j'ai à
peine le temps de me remettre de découpe
à ce qu'on se fait quand même mal dans
les autos que tout de suite en remontrer
ambulante et et ça finit par face au
difficile c'est ken tyrrell qui a donné
sa chance à jean tyrrell le découvreur
de talents qui pense beaucoup de bien de
lui
vous l'avez compris je pense qu'il sera
le prochain champion du monde pensait à
l'éthique a encore tout à prouver mais
était peut-être un signe
en juillet dernier lors de son premier
grand prix qu'il marque des points seul
prost avait fait aussi bien
alain prost qui pose aux côtés de nigel
mansell son futur coéquipier c'est la
référence pour tous les jeunes pilotes
français a lancé le pilote suprême
et c'est le pilote qui a le plus de
victoires en grand prix et c'est
impossible de se comparer à lui il a il
a beaucoup de prod2 il a un palmarès
trop trop et on fait le palmarès d'aller
y reste à écrire
à 25 ans il a prouvé qu'il a la tête sur
les épaules qu'il est bon metteur au
point qu'il va vite et qu'en plus il a
de l'humour cinéma ça tombe bien les
stars fonde sur deauville comme batman
sur ses ennemis batman c'est le film qui
fait courir toute l'amérique qui a été
présenté à deauville
les stars se sont donc mickey rourke kim
basinger ou kim novak qui sont là
deauville c'est donc le festival du film
américain
jean jacques dufour notre star à nous
n'est pas dépaysé là bas cette année
encore le festival du film américain a
rendu hommage à de nombreuses stars en
leur présence et notamment kim novak
envers mitchum lauren bacall
il l'a pas rendu hommage en revanche ami
pierrot et kim basinger c'est normal ils
sont encore un peu jeune mais il était
là et bien là
mickey rourke pour la projection du film
de walter hill johnny belle gueule
un polar très noir
mick et interprète de johnny un petit
voyou défiguré que la chirurgie
esthétique va transformer
mika manque le thème du film c'est la
vengeance est aussi le droit au rachat
vous croyez que c'est possible de
repartir à zéro
oui je crois
et à propos qu'est ce que vous pensez de
votre gueule ouais c'est comment est ce
que je pense de ma gueule
et bien qu'elle est changeante puisque
nous parlons de minois nous avons
rencontré celui charmant de kim basinger
afin d'évoquer avec elle son dernier
rôle celui de fiancé de batman
j'adore michael keaton qui interprète
batman c'est un très bon comédien
maintenant est-ce que c'est mon type
d'homme et bruce wayne et vous faites
quoi dans ma vie et bien batman il fait
un malheur et des tas de petites choses
sourit en or pour les producteurs une
chauve-souris deux mètres à gotham city
low cost une chèque reste ayant le
costume comme la batmobile vous ne
pouvez pas kim
je pense qu'il ya une petite partie de
moi qui adore batman dans son costume
mais il est tellement tendre sexy enfin
vous voyez moins sexy mais formidable
dans son numéro deux pitres grimaçant
jack nicholson qui interprète le joker
l'ennemi juré de batman
film aux somptueux décors bien jouer
batman feige peut-être quand même par la
faiblesse de son scénario a tranché
nous y serons c'est fantastique jouer
oui mais il ya kim basinger quand même
les pronos pour le tiercé c'est dommage
et vrilles voici ce que nous propose
pierrette brès 13,9 5,16 de 7 15 12
la météo s'est tout de suite joseph dans
la pierre nous dira si le ciel va nous
tomber sur la tête pendant le week-end
je ne crois pas à vrai dire dernière
édition henri sannier 23 heures aussitôt
après apostrophe de pivot ce week-end
pour l'info vous retrouverez le célèbre
trio bilalian du rogas saut et lundi à
20 heures christine ockrent sera aux
commandes
bon week end